[Music]
it's nine o'clock this is sky news
welcome to our new show where i'm going
to interview people who have something
to say about the world today and how
it's changing they'll be from politics
sport business entertainment public life
or they'll be everyday people caught up
in the events of our times i'll be
putting my questions to tonight's
special guests
[Music]
good evening however hard we might try
we can't tear our eyes from ukraine
towns like mario paul and kharkiv places
we barely heard of but weeks ago are now
at the forefront of our minds being
consumed in an onslaught with no end in
sight and it's civilians who are paying
the price international condemnation
continues but can russian forces be
stopped this man should know once an
oligarch then jailed for 10 years in a
siberian prison camp he's now described
by some as president putin's leading
critic in exile and tonight he warns
that the west have got this badly wrong
england's premier league is the most
successful the richest and perhaps the
most exciting in the world but has that
come at too high a price the war in
ukraine shone a light on some of the
money that's flowed into the game and
caused a major crisis at one of the
world's most glamorous clubs chelsea i
sat down with former england star and
just maybe future politician gary
neville to get his take on the mixing of
football and politics
and what is the role of the police in
tackling violence against women and
girls if you don't think sexual assault
harassment and worse are a completely
normal part of life in this country ask
a woman how she feels last year a senior
policewoman was appointed to tackle this
epidemic and tonight maggie blythe is on
the show in her first tv interview since
her appointment no doubt her heart's in
the right place but is the police's
the threat of violence against women and
girls is a huge daily fear for millions
of british women
it rose to the fall last year with some
high profile cases like the murder of
sarah everard but it remains a fact of
life week after week how can we explain
then that rape cases are at record highs
and convictions at record lows let's
speak now to the person appointed to
tackle that issue deputy chief constable
maggie blythe the first national lead
for violence against women and girls in
the police force maggie thanks so much
uh for coming on the show tonight this
is something that i care a lot about i
know lots of women do
let's talk fast about the scale of this
problem
rape cases are at record highs over 60
000 cases reported to the police in the
year to september 2021 convictions at
record lows an estimated 1.6 million
women the victims of domestic abuse 680
000
women victims of sexual assault 110
women killed in the uk by men in 2020
can you in good faith tell women
watching
this interview watching us talk that if
they suffer violence or abuse and go to
the police that they'll get justice in
this country
good evening and thank you for inviting
me along this evening yes in answer to
your question i do think that women
should and must
feel confident in reporting offences
relating to sexual assault domestic
abuse to the police because we are
absolutely determined to address what
you've just described as an epidemic and
we know that and we want to prioritize
changing how we work within policing and
how we address uh the challenges that we
know we've got ahead
and maggie um
i guess part of the argument has been
that the police could be part of of the
problem not the solution and there's a
number of reasons i say that but one
reason is when i uh interviewed the
prime minister about this back in
october at conservative party conference
uh i asked him about the appalling
statistics around rape prosecutions and
he said to me people don't have enough
confidence in the criminal justice
system and they don't have a feeling
that the police are handling these
issues fast enough which has led to this
feeling of fury and frustration so he
kind of put it back on the criminal
justice
system but also on the police how do you
feel about that when you hear him say
that do you share some of the blame or
do you think he's shifting the blame
i'm listening to what women and girls
say to me every day at the moment and i
think that trust and confidence issue is
absolutely right
and policing knows that we've lost the
trust and confidence of many communities
particularly women and girls uh across
across our country and that's something
that really concerns us um and we we
know uh particularly in the last few
months and some of the events some of
the tragic deaths of of women last year
have really really changed um how
some communities particularly women and
girls feel about policing so yes we hear
that trust and confidence
and maggie i mean
one of the good news is is that you've
been appointed the lead in the police to
actually tackle this across police
forces so uh priti patel the home
secretary said to me that she wanted to
make it a national priority and she's
put you in place which means it has
become a national priority which is a
positive thing but i guess the thing is
is that
what follows through from that and one
of the questions i had for you
is that
does your appointment does the fact the
government's making this a national
priority mean that in practice the
government now might hit these rate
review targets that they set
and that was to get to nearly five over
5000 prosecutions and nearly 3 000
convictions by 2024 that's going back to
2016. you'll know all of this uh levels
last year prostitutions were 1500 just
to put it in some context can you give
the commitment today now that you think
with you at the lead and this
prioritization that the government can
hit those targets and women can have
confidence by 2024 the government will
hit those targets what i can talk about
is i'm absolutely committed to
ensuring that the things that need to
change do change within policing but we
also know
that we have to work with other sectors
with a range of other different
organizations including the cps if we're
really going to make a difference for
the criminal justice system as a whole
so i'm ambitious for change and i know
that we have a plan and will make some
uh significant changes over the next
year two years moving forward but we
we're talking long-term
in terms of really changing realistic
are they those in terms of really
changing the attitudes of men and boys
towards women and girls is going to take
time that isn't going to just happen
overnight that we're going to see and i
increasingly
i do want to come to that but they're
not realistic targets are they i mean
let's be straight i think we have to
have targets for improving both charges
and prosecutions around rape and serious
sexual offences and domestic abuse we
have to have those targets and the cps
and the police are working together
around them but we also have to be
realistic
that the criminal justice system alone
and particularly on the back of a
pandemic where we know we've got the
backlogs in the courts we have is it's
going to take time to bring those
changes and until we address the trust
and confidence which you you you
introduced at the beginning i think
we've got some difficulties ahead
just to be clear then
the targets are important but the time
frame might not be hit is that fair i
think the time frame it's going to take
years to really change our chromosomes
okay so not not being realistic not yeah
not hit by 2024 which i think is a
fair and straight answer
um
let's talk about the police and your
role
the evarah case devastated women's
confidence in the police and and that
was compounded by the policing of the
vigil at clapham common there were the
whatsapp messages about rape and
violence and domestic violence from the
charing cross police station and then
this week there was the strip searching
of a young black girl child q at her own
school which has has really upset with
upset people
it's a problem isn't it
the incidents and the cases and the
particular matter around child q are
really disturbing and are shocking shock
me and shock the people that i work with
and i think even more reason why we need
to have a plan and a priority around
tackling violence against women and
girls it's on the level of of an
epidemic in terms of the information and
the data that we have
you outlined at the beginning we know
what the problem is so we we know that
it's it's an issue for society and
therefore what we see in society we will
also see in policing but we also know
that this is something that we have to
keep shining the light on and the more
that we do i think the more cases we're
going to see coming to light around our
own workforce around police officers and
staff
behaving in a way that falls below the
standard that we would expect within
policing and we will root that out and
already are on the way to do that
through the plans that we have because
mike actually you now you bring it up i
mean dozens of male police officers are
continuing to exploit their position and
take sexual advantage of women 66
officers and members of the police
you'll know this face disciplinary
proceedings for alleged abuse of
position for sexual
purpose have you witnessed any of these
attitudes among your colleagues
personally first of all just to go back
there there is an absolute plan to root
out any any behavior or conduct that
falls below what we would expect in
policing and the many officers and staff
that i work with and i have led over the
last few years want that we don't want
people in policing that uh bring down
the reputation of policing
and don't fit with the ethics and values
we hold
are so important so really important to
know that there's that plan in terms of
what what um i see i i yes i i
experience and see what women tell me um
they've faced with within policing and
and in other professions working
alongside policing um and it's really
important that we have a culture where
those things are talked about amongst
our teams and our supervisors and women
concerns you've been a senior police
officer you you've
personally experienced sexism and i have
been really supported in my career
through policing i wouldn't be here i
wouldn't be doing the job i'm doing if i
didn't feel that policing is a fantastic
career and something to enjoy and be
part of um that's really important i
think to get across i want women to come
and join policing i'm really pleased
that we've got about 42 in our latest
round coming to join policing but yes
i've seen sexism and i know that
misogyny exists in in police forces
and police the police service as a whole
and really important that we tackle that
it exists because it exists in society
but i think there also is perhaps
something about being attracted to power
being attracted to
um
a culture that some
largely men may
find find attractive and want to come
into um and
because of the coat the ability to
coerce and abuse more people that are
more vulnerable so i think there's
always that possibility which we see in
other professions as well
and our vetting and and our culture has
to be one where
in teams people can have those
conversations and call out and feel that
they will be listened to if they feel so
you feel the more women in the police
force the more that dilutes that culture
that male culture i think it does it
absolutely dilutes it but also diversity
and and having men as we do have who
want to be
very strong allies for calling out
inappropriate culture and being part of
that change
just one quick question on
the most prominent police women in the
country cressida dick
did you think she was treated unfairly
or was it understandable she had to go
how did you feel about that as a fellow
senior policewoman the met commissioner
is a fantastic role model for for women
in policing um
her resignation really is a matter for
um the mayor of london and the home
secretary so i wouldn't comment but a
great role model for women in policing
so you found her inspiring absolutely
absolutely um
let's just tackle another problem i'm
actually running out i've got so many
questions um you talked about male
culture in the police but it's the real
problem against with violence against
women and girls male culture in our
society has it got worse or are we
getting more vocal about not putting up
with it i i think very much the latter
i've um in a working career of over 30
years and i've seen changes in in that
working career around our society but
there are attitudes we know still
prevail and i think a tipping point
which i have referred to others have
referred to as a watershed moment of
last year coming out of the pandemic the
spotlight that's been shown on what
happens behind closed doors and
sometimes in in public places to women
and girls and the everyone's invited
website that's set up by by girls and
y'all and young women um accounting for
for the things that have happened to
them i think women and girls are saying
enough we we don't want to be treated
like this we don't have to have and put
up with that type of behavior and that
is a moment in time for me and my career
for for me um as as a woman in society
and i think we need to grab that moment
and to use what we know with that
information you started out with this
morning the epidemic in front of us we
need to be able to address it but
policing has to do that by working with
other
agencies with education
with the rest of the criminal justice
system with health because ultimately
this is i think a public health issue
around
violence
and maggie obviously focus of forces
help
people speaking about it
helps but in practical terms what would
help you in terms of policing would it
help for example if misogyny became a
help
hate crime would it help if public
sexual harassment became a specific
offense
i want to keep the spotlight on violence
against women and girls
i want there to be lasting change for
how women and girls feel safe in our
society i want women and girls to trust
policing and the plan we have i think
will go a long way to that but i think
it's a complex one misogyny is a hate
crime the government has accepted the
law commission advice that um it won't
be um included as a hate crime and
policing
enforces the laws we don't make it um i
think it's perhaps a very symbolic
gesture to have have done to make
misogyny hate crime but perhaps doesn't
really get to the root of the problem
that if we sexual harassment
well well i think the root of the
problem is behaviour and attitudes of
boys and men we've got lots of offences
already um and we know that consistently
we don't use them as well as we should
across our 43 police forces we don't use
some of the protective orders that we've
got to keep women and girls safe well
enough so let's get working on that and
let's get looking at the education and
the changing attitudes of boys and men
before we think we need more laws
because i think prevention and education
and tackling attitudes isn't necessarily
about creating new legislation
so i'm not entirely convinced but we
will work with government as they look
into uh whether new laws are needed
around street-based harassment um and we
will we will want to recognize that
there are additional pressures in the
21st century online that might mean new
legislation well we are going to get the
online harms bill so well look maggie i
would like to carry on but i've got to
wrap that but thank you for coming on
and i hope you'll come back again in a
few months time and we could look at
some of the stats and see if we're going
the right way or the wrong way thank you
thank you so much welcome back we're
going to have an interview with mikhail
kordikovsky soon but first has english
football sold its soul did it ever have
one russia's invasion of ukraine
prompted the west to sanction
individuals and businesses alleged to
have connection with russian president
vladimir putin among those to have their
assets frozen is roman abramovich owner
of the chelsea football club and chelsea
isn't the only top club to be accused of
being funded from morally compromised
sources it's a challenge to those
thousands of football fans who have
faith in the beautiful game who see in
it lyricism and humanity people like for
example gary neville
once a star of manchester united and
england now a respected pundit and
businessman
right ready you feeling the pressure
yeah a little bit right ready
gary thanks for coming on my show
i'm really really happy to have you on
my show this is how yeah i'm happy to be
honest i'm really happy this is
congratulations on uh
did you win this show i won it we had a
penalty strikeout and i uh i was
victorious yeah anyway look thanks for
coming on we actually are in football
goals but i will talk to you a bit about
football but i also want to talk to you
a bit about your career and also about
politics because you are quite
politically engaged and i've noticed it
because we've interacted a bit on
twitter and and you're quite into
politics and you you're really
clued up on what's going on but i wanted
to start and just ask you about ukraine
because
people on both the left and right have
spoken about how ukraine's provided a
moment of clarity
about a reminder if you like of what our
fundamental values are have have you
felt that as well
i think so i think one of the reasons
over the last four or five years that
i've probably become more politically
engaged has been because of the wheat
leadership
not just in this country my
disappointment in the leadership in this
country but also internationally
obviously brexit and the fact that we've
been separated from our european friends
our neighbours people who we respect and
love and love us
who we should have a strong relationship
with and also the us obviously the trump
administration which again was
in my mind farcical
and so what we've seen is basically over
the last four or five years
a weaker west
that's i think been exploited uh in the
last few weeks and the ukrainian people
suffer for it out of the ukrainian
suffering comes a strengthened west
where people you know we've recognized
that actually we are
on the same side that we should work
together we need to collaborate we need
to make sure that we unify and
but you shouldn't need what's happening
in ukraine at the moment for that to
happen
but there's always been that sort of old
cliche about sports and politics not
mixing it seems a bit hollow now doesn't
it because the two things have
completely bled into each other haven't
they in in recent
recent days over ukraine and the
sanctions and and also kind of what's
happened in terms of sporting events and
russia being excluded
i think i've always felt that sport
should rise above politics and
um
even international crises that happen
however i think i'm wrong
uh i've always welcomed international
money into premier league football i've
always felt that we should welcome the
saudi arabian money the uae money the
russian money and that we should try and
through football and through sport
create
what would be a better collaborative
working relationship improve conditions
for the populations of these countries
which yeah in large part they do suffer
they do don't always have the freedom
and the democracies that we and the
choices that we have however i have to
say that's been
tested enormously in this last few weeks
with what's happened with chelsea with
abramovich with the ukraine war the
connections between abramovich and putin
government have obviously closed chelsea
down effectively at this moment in time
other than the fact they can play
football matches
my long-held view that football and
sport should try and
welcome
this international money in
i feel a lot weaker on that opinion
i was going to ask you that about that
guy actually because um on march the 1st
i had look you did an ft financial times
football summit and you said you
wouldn't have kicked abromovich out of
english football and you actually said
he broke the old elite because he
brought new money in and he broke the
kind of top tier and he kind of got and
sort of chelsea in
that was on march the first it's what
now march the 17th do you
even now do you think actually
you misjudged that or you've changed
your view i think what i was saying in
that particular interview is i welcome
the competitive nature the competitive
change english football the idea of
manchester united arsenal and liverpool
being the traditional elite always being
at the top always having the most money
i like the idea of the fact that they've
been challenged by manchester city
newcastle now obviously blackburn
historically with jack walker who's a
local businessman and obviously roman
abramovich's chelsea i believe they've
added to the to the premier league's
global appeal the competitive landscape
of the game in this country the the
quality of the football that we see but
at what cost at what cost and i have to
say i've always welcomed it
um
i welcome into international investments
into cities but then i think the line
has been crossed and it's obviously been
crossed so you in the last few years so
you sort of see it as a moment of
reckoning for english football now
absolutely a moment of reckoning i don't
think the premier league can continue to
bury the heads in the sand and feel as
though i mean at the moment we don't
even know where the premier league stand
on these big issues at times they waited
for the government to act before they
suspended uh
romney brunovic as a director he'd
almost already had the club taking off
him at that point yeah um the premier
league
it's it's
it's chasing them down the street
the issues around independence
transparency fit and proper owners test
redistribution of funds looking after
grassroots football they can continue to
ignore it but it's coming for them and i
think this crisis in the last few weeks
has made it incredibly difficult for
them to ignore that there's got to be a
better way forward you know you're
talking about some of the richest
businessmen in the world states in the
world now owning not owning english
football clubs which i say it's made it
such a competitive game it's made it a
brilliant game but it's been basically
uh it's happening without control
without independence and without
transparency in our game in this country
is far too important for deals to be
done because we still don't know how
saudi arabia were accepted into this
country as a football club owner we have
no idea we know that they're in we know
that they met the criteria but no one
knows what the criteria and you would
have seen yesterday that the chelsea
boss thomas teacher made that point why
is it right for chelsea to be punished
over russian's invasion of ukraine but
newcastle have not been punished
given that saudi arabia are involved in
a war in yemen i mean there is a
contradiction there isn't there that's a
you're absolutely right and i say i'm
happy to say i'm happy to uh say that
i've been wrong on this particular issue
i think it's taken the ukraine war for
me to recognize that
that we cannot accept
money into football in this country that
is tainted
and there's no doubt that we have done
so gary following on from that do you
think that it should be right that the
premier league asks owners to sign
declaration supporting human rights or
there's an independent regulator that
checks these things before
people are allowed to buy clubs like
there should be more regulation of the
sector now well 100 i've been calling
for independent regulator for two or
three years and that has to come in that
has to be a priority because there is a
crisis in english football every 10
minutes you know whether it be derby
county whether it be the super league
project whether it be abramovich in the
last few weeks there is no way that the
premier the premier league have proven
that they're not fit and proper and
they're not capable of demonstrating the
leadership that's needed in english
football so that will change
um i think just generally this is a
wake-up a wake-up call i think for all
football clubs
associations organizations that
we can't just separate ourselves from
the political and social
uh issues that are surrounding us we are
intertwined in it because of the
ownership structures that exist in
english football at this moment in time
well look gary let's come on to talking
about you and your
uh
sort of interaction between football and
politics and also
just all your business interests so
let's kick off with
you know i've been reading a lot about
you the two things that have really
struck me is you're very busy
and you're very driven generally you're
very you're a tv expert you're a social
media influencer you own hotels you're a
restauranteur you're a football club
owner you set up a university you've
just joined the labour party and you get
up at 4 30 am and your motto is attack
the day there's this relentlessness
about you i mean for start how did your
family cope with it they don't really
they ignore me at times and just let me
get on with it actually it's the name of
my business relentless
it's my favorite word in the world
because i don't think it does stop i
think that you have an opportunity in
life you you're here for a very short
period of time i think you go for it you
attack the day you make every moment
count it wasn't i wasn't born like that
it's my parents my upbringing my coaches
my manager at manchester united
surrounded by brilliant people who set
the right example
and we have two choices when we wake up
every single day we're either going to
go for it and try our very best and not
give in or the opposite of that and for
me there's only one way to go you have
obviously you set up a university you
have a you have a business i mean you
run you manage 600 people i mean you're
you're a serious businessman aside from
all of your other interests around
football but you have said that
when you're 50 which is in three years
time it's the next phase of your life it
seems to me from observing you a bit
it's a question of uh if not when you
get into politics is that fair i don't
think so i mean i'm obviously i joined
the labour party i wanted to i felt
compelled to
i do
feel compelled to
real disappointment with the existing
government
we have to be better than that we have
to be better than that and i think in
the last two or three weeks it's
absolutely right that you know the
labour party liberal democrats the snp
people who comment on sort of what the
political situations are backed off
because it's important that we have
unity at this moment in time that we
concentrate and focus on what's needed
in ukraine and support those people and
not if you like let politics get in the
way of it however the baton has just
been placed on the floor it needs
picking up again do you think that the
conservative party should have a policy
now that they don't accept any money
from russian donors unless it's someone
that's opposed to the putin regime i
mean they've laundered the money through
this city for the last 10 years they've
poisoned people on our streets
um they've invested into our
current
serving government party
i'd suggest that that's something that
doesn't need to be said
i mean we need to be very light on this
at this moment in time because it takes
away from the focus of making sure that
boris johnson who to be fair doesn't
need much to distract him but at this
moment in time he needs to focus
on ukraine and making sure he makes the
rights that's why i'm leaving off him
that's why so you don't think he should
resign at the moment at this moment in
time i would say that ultimately
there needs to be a focus completely on
him doing his job which is supporting
the british government in making sure
that everything that needs to happen in
ukraine happens however the second that
hopefully this crisis is over or it
subsides he needs to leave because he is
a danger to our country the standards
that
we have gotten zero credibility
in europe and around the world we need a
government who can rebuild our
relationships and our standards
gary when you i mean just to be clear
they
the the government would would contest
that but of course when just to be clear
though i mean
when you're when you're kind you're so
sorry
but you have a very visceral dislike for
boris johnson but you also have this
very public role as a kind of leading
football in star and commentator do you
ever get
blowback from fans that don't like it
because millions of people voted for
boris johnson of course and they don't
like you talking about that absolutely
and absolutely i've got look
they're smart operators i've no doubt
that when they get when they say get
brexit done and when they say get
leveling up it's hitting home because
they've got data behind them to support
it they socially engineer our minds
we've got to get back to what's
important in this country except
millions of people have voted for him
i'm hopeful that brexit was a big part
of that and ultimately they're also
weakness of the of the opposition
but i'd like to think in two years time
that we have a we have a better place to
go to in terms of leaders i'm going to
ask you two more things
so one just going back to politics i
want to pin you down a bit what about
running education for the government
in under labour government cabinet
minister
geosynthetic i'm really passionate about
education i know you so i mean you sound
really passionate about education
because i do believe it should be the
heart health and education should be the
heart of every government policy so you
would maybe want to be an mp and a
cabinet minister i love the idea of
having an influence in education and set
up a university you know when i see two
weeks ago that this current government
have gone out to consultation
to remove student loans
from students who don't achieve a c a
are seeing
in at gcc level in english and maths it
breaks my heart
20 20 to 25 of students in this country
currently go to university without an
english and maths level c at gcse level
yeah subjects like pe sports science
subjects like in the digital sector
where many of the jobs current jobs
exist
um
you would be excluding people from
disadvantaged backgrounds low income
families because that's it they are not
ordinarily the students who don't have
that we we've got to change the way in
which we look at education so it seems
to me that you don't want to do the
mayoral race but what i'm hearing is
someone
that does want to dedicate their life
even more to public service because
you've done a lot already but that
doesn't necessarily have to be through
being an mp or necessarily through sort
of being in public office because i do
like the idea of my freedom i like the
idea of what i do in manchester with
guys you definitely seem attracted to it
i'll just something i like i i want to
have a positive i want to have a
positive impact on the people that i'm
sort of come into contact with i really
feel passionate about the opportunity
that i was given
as an 18 year old by a great manager who
looked at me equally as one of the
experienced players in the team and i
think that everybody was a leader you
know you led the youth team you captain
menu you can't help it it's kind of in
you isn't it
it seems to me like it is look i i love
i want everyone to have the best
opportunity that they can you know
sounds really sort of twee
and but the fact the matter is
i'm really struggling with a look at the
chancellor beth yeah he's worth half a
billion quid he wakes up one morning and
he says i'm going to lend people in this
country are desperately trying to afford
their energy bills 200 quid but what i'm
going to do i'm going to make them pay
me back over five years at 40 quid a
year i don't want that type of guy but
the only way you change it is if you go
into politics gary i know but that's
honestly i i think we can i think
sometimes i can have more influence with
my twitter follow with my twitter
following now that i can five million
followers i'd probably have to
definitely not ruling it in yeah but i
do see some decisions that are made we
have mps at this moment in time who vote
for children in the first wave of a
pandemic not to eat food that really
disturbs me
okay i'm going to ask you one final
question
who would you rather work for liverpool
football club or the conservative oh my
goodness gracious he's fallen off the
chair oh
do you know something i have to say
a hundred percent
liverpool football club and just
something you know how much i don't like
them that's why
i look at jurgen klopp jordan henderson
they're the two leaders in that club at
this moment in time on the football
pitch and off the football pitch they're
good men they're good people they're
honest
let's start with that shall we as the
basic sort of fundamentals of a leader
in this country and move away from what
would be the sort of shenanigans and
shambles that we've had for this last
six months
all right well gary neville i suspect
i'll be seeing you down in westminster
in the future yeah headline gary
neville's joining liverpool
well you see what i did there all right
thanks so thanks so much for the show
thoroughly enjoyed that thank you
welcome back what's in the mind of
vladimir putin to help answer that
question i've spoken to one of his
oldest adversaries mikhail kordakovsky
was a billionaire or boss and a
supporter of democratic reforms in
russia but he lost both his money and
his freedom when he was sent to jail
reportedly at the orders of putin now
from london he leads open russia a
global network supporting russian
opposition groups
mr kudakovsky
thank you for talking to us today
there's so much to talk about
your group open russia
keeps closely in touch with the mood of
russia
what is going on
[Music]
because
people are afraid to pick a site because
of what will happen to them i mean you
were imprisoned for how long a decade
so what's going on
in russia now
a
foreign are you angry that some of the
oligarchs that have been sanctioned by
the u.s the uk
the european union that people will not
speak out
leading figures
in russian society very few of them will
speak out does that make you angry or is
that what you expected
yep
[Music]
[Music]
okay
let's come to
why they might not do it and and
president putin
you've known him for decades
you were his ally once you supported him
you fought him
uh you were incarcerated by him he
effectively expelled you from the
country that you
would love to live in
how do you feel about him now do you
hate him do you fear him
[Music]
you say putin is a war criminal you say
he's a fascist
has he changed since you first knew him
[Music]
would you do would you
implement the no-fly zone would you
actually
recommend that those powers go into
nuclear into conflict with putin knowing
that that could lead to nuclear
escalation i would argue that they're in
a very difficult
situation and it must be very difficult
to take that decision
problem
[Music]
i wasn't going to ask you this but i am
actually going to ask you this you
talked about putin being a fascist
you've also just referenced the
beginning of the second world war in
1938 to 1939.
are you saying that you think that
president putin
isn't
it resembles in some way
hitler
bisekov
your message it seems to me to to
western leaders is crystal clear today
do you think then
defeating putin there is inevitability
that nuclear weapons could be used
because that's what the west fears right
that's what we
[Music]
[Music]
i mean you clearly think the west are
following the wrong strategy and you
know the manual
um
i want to ask you about your future now
just about you
litvinenko salisbury other reputed
attacks on individuals in
britain
putin gave a televised address yesterday
in which he talked about scum traitors
as being midges we spit out they were
his words
you sit here and you say he's a fascist
that he's like hitler
you i can see the contempt actually the
rage you feel towards him do you ever
feel
fear for your life or feel scared
about speaking out
yet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well michael thank you so much
uh if i could say thank you in russian i
would
um
how do you sir
thank you thank you
well mikhail korokovsky there with his
view a warning that putin will never
stop in his view unless western use
leaders use direct military force that's
his view thanks for joining us